un feu chez vous dans le Nord qui a
forcé l'évacuation de 800 personnes
c'est la moitié de la municipalité
n'est-ce pas
oui exactement
bon alors racontez-moi comment ça s'est
fait puis qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit pour la suite des choses
donc comment ça s'est passé tout d'abord
c'est ça entre autres et hier dans les
alentours de 14h14h30 là on a vu le feu
prendre beaucoup d'ampleur en fait donc
la saupe feu a été déployée les pompiers
la municipalité ont été déployés pour
aller constater les lieux et puis
d'abord c'est les illégiateurs qui
étaient vraiment près du feu là on parle
de 100 m 50 mètres même pour certains
résidents donc les si on était évacués
en urgence et voir la municipalité pour
leur sécurité ensuite le feu a construit
de se propager donc elle s'est rendu en
villégiature au niveau du lac presque
qui est à ce moment-là qui est tout près
de la municipalité également on a évacué
également ces gens-là pour leur sécurité
on se rendait bien compte que avec les
vins qui tournaient l'incertitude pour
assurer la sécurité au maximum de gens
possibles on a pris la décision
d'évacuer la moitié de la municipalité
vers nous qui l'avait le voisine
toujours
dans un contexte de minimiser les dégâts
puis de
protéger les gens finalement est-ce que
ça pourrait est-ce que ça s'empire ou ça
s'améliore autour de chapelle
donc actuellement les dernières
informations qu'on a c'est certain que
j'attends toujours les informations plus
récentes pour la soirée mais celle qu'on
a eu en dernièrement cet après-midi là
on parlait de vent qui était favorables
donc les vents ne pointaient plus vers
la ville ce qui est une bonne chose
cependant le feu est toujours d'une
grande ampleur mais toujours pas
maîtrisée non plus donc il reste quand
même quelques incertitudes à ce niveau
là et est-ce qu'on tente chez vous de le
combattre on va parler à quelqu'un un
peu plus tard de la sope feu il y a
certains feux où on est presque mieux de
le laisser brûler mais c'est trop
compliqué qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit sur
l'opération là actuellement
donc actuellement j'attends toujours les
directives de la stop feu puis le
rapport de fin de journée par contre je
sais qu'ils ont passé la journée sur les
lieux à tenter de le maîtriser ou du
moins à évaluer le plan de match les
stratégie pour bon c'est ça minimiser
les dégâts assurer la sécurité des
citoyens mais j'attends toujours leur
rapport final pour pour ce qui est
d'aujourd'hui en espérant que celui-ci
sera optimiste pour ne pas être obligé
de faire évacuer le reste des gens les
est-ce que les gens évacués vous êtes
bien encadrés par la les vous avez eu
l'aide de Québec nécessaire tout va bien
et oui tout à fait à ce niveau là les
villes la voisine ont été très
proactives afin de nous appuyer les
députés fédérales et provinciales sont
sur place avec nous à la municipalité
pour nous épauler également donc à ce
niveau là on est très bien accompagné
Isabelle les sœurs merci beaucoup vous
en avez c'est votre première crise à
gérer là depuis que vous avez été élu je
me sens j'ai fait une entrée avec vous
c'est une des plus jeunes sinon la plus
jeune mais reste du Québec
oui tout à fait effectivement c'est une
grosse crise pour commencer un mandat
bravo en tout cas n'ont pas bravo pour
ce qui se passe mais bravo pour votre
sang-froid puis je vous entends depuis
ce matin puis bonne chance pour la suite
merci beaucoup au revoir
et en boucle la boucle avec Stéphane
Caron au corps de Nathan à la prévention
à la sub bonsoir Monsieur Caron bonsoir
bon d'abord sur le nombre de fleurs on a
vu celui de cette île on a vu chapelle
dans le Nord combien il y a de feu
actifs au Québec
on fait sur notre site Internet vous
pouvez voir qu'il y a 42 feux actifs qui
sont inscrits mais ce n'est pas le
Portrait Complet parce que en ce moment
il y a eu un passage de foudre important
il y a beaucoup d'éclosions de feu donc
en ce moment il y a beaucoup de feux
dans la ligne d'attente si on peut dire
donc on évalue à au moins une
soixantaine d'autres feux qui sont en
activité pour un total d'une centaine
c'est beaucoup pour le Québec OK dans
quelle région essentiellement est-ce
qu'on parle du Nord côte nord ou ça
c'est sur l'ensemble du territoire
en ce moment c'est sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc il y a des secteurs qui
ont été identifiés par la soft-fute des
secteurs forestiers essentiellement où
il y a pas nécessairement de communautés
ou d'infrastructures stratégiques donc
dans ces secteurs ne seront pas
priorisés pour le combat comme tel ils
vont être surveillés on va faire en
sorte d'identifier clairement qu'il y a
pas de communauté ou d'infrastructures
stratégique qui serait menacée mais donc
on est rendu à une situation où on doit
laisser aller certains feux pour
prioriser les feux où il y a un danger
pour les populations on peut s'attaquer
à combien de feux à la subscrit en même
temps parce que vous êtes déjà au bout
de vos ressources
enfin on évalue ça dépend toujours de la
grosseur des feux là mais quand on
arrive à 30 feux simultanés on atteint
la capacité opérationnelle de la surfe
donc on a déjà dépassé cette capacité là
c'est pas une catastrophe le faut pas la
remuer les gens ça veut simplement dire
que notre notre façon de faire qui vise
à éteindre tous les feux dans notre zone
de protection intensive là on est plus
capable d'atteindre cet objectif là on
doit prioriser les feux en ce moment à
cause notamment de la foudre qui s'est
bien s'ajouter au feu de causes humaines
on est dans une situation où on a
vraiment un grand nombre de vues est-ce
qu'il y en a qui vous inquiète
particulièrement là sur le sur
l'ensemble parce que la faute ça semble
être l'élément nouveau aujourd'hui là
que déjà vous en aviez pas mal plein à
votre assiette là ça s'ajoute là
tout à fait c'est sûr qu'on regarde de
très proches les feux qui sont au nord
de cette île ces feux là on a déployé
une équipe de gestion de feu majeurs
pour intervenir parce que il y a
certains dangers éventuellement et
notamment vous parlez tantôt de la fumée
c'est vrai que au-delà du feu la fumée
peut être très encommandante pour les
communautés il y a évidemment Chapet
avec pour lequel vous avez eu entrevue
avec un reste à chapit aussi on a
déployé une équipe de gestion de feu
majeur aujourd'hui les on a des
tranchées qui ont été construites de
façon mécanisée donc on intervient sur
ces feux là en particulier donc
l'évaluation qu'on a fait pour chacun
des feux et vraiment basé sur les
communautés et les infrastructures
stratégiques monsieur Caron votre pause
arrivera quand il va pleuvoir
inévitablement là dans un but comme on
vit actuellement c'est la mère nature
qui va réguler la situation avec de la
pluie on a aussi un phénomène qui des
fois avec les oranges les orages ne nous
aide pas nécessairement parce que vont
amener un peu plus mais surtout la
foudre qui va allumer des feux puis
demain on s'attend je vous parlais
tantôt de au moins une soixantaine de
feu là quand on va qu'on a dans la ligne
d'attente mais on s'attend à en trouver
quelques dizaines d'autres
merci beaucoup monsieur Carron on va se
reparler je le sens merci bonne journée
bonne chance au revoir